so time came Brown no we're all set a
music video for good as you and this is
my mini-me Lonnie hey first of all the
the most funnest thing here was meeting
you because he's such a great person and
he has such an awesome truck that is the
biggest truck and this is a really great
song I've listened to your songs a good
job my mom my dad my Nana was a mom you
know it's just awesome I guess being
raised by women because I can relate to
them so much it kind of helped me in the
room and yeah so this is just an awesome
video just basically the picture need
some onion on my mom just how they
raised me and I grew up a little
different I was always bullied in school
so that was hard and it's just I would
grew up with hardly any money and I feel
like there's a lot of things that here
where you can actually really see how I
was raised
so I can't wait to see the
I still watch a lot of YouTube videos of
people just dancing freestyle and
beatboxing I started beatboxing first
and I am not getting done at all but now
I involved and I'm dancing doing nothing
else yeah but you guys say y'all that's
my favorite thing meeting him is amazing
this is amazing
and I really
[Music]